[Musique]
et pourquoi interrogé à savoir d'où l'on
vient
le recul marqué d'equalia sur c'est quoi
tu veilles flanc on est plus tard dès
lors que la ci par exemple on ne fait
une table ronde avec quatre acteurs
assez importante milieu au québec oui on
a posé la question à des digues
sociologue de l'amortisseur des
historiens de la culture culinaire
la réponse est jamais là même
honnêtement je pense que c'est un
questionnement qui reste ouvert même
après la lecture de caribous oui oui si
ça trouve qu'il ya quelque chose à dire
là dessus ce qui ressort du coup c'est
les influences vers concept s'effectuer
c'est ce que j'allais dire oui bon parce
qu'on est arrivé sur un territoire qui
était peuplée par les autochtones donc
c'est sûr qui a une incidence des
autochtones les anglophones également
venu d'irlande décosse d'angleterre et
puis bien sûr de la france et sur tous
les produits qu'on retrouve sur le
territoire québécois qui sont certains
sont uniques aussi au québec tout à fait
vous avez bien résumé mais c'est
effectivement été inquiet en fleurs qui
sont très vert qui ressortent souvent
qui ont par contre été perdu quand on
parle des peuples autochtones ya pas eu
beaucoup d'écrits c'est ce que les gens
déplore beaucoup quand on les questionne
sur le sujet on a un peu perdu sort en
même temps il ya des traces qui sont
restés aussi donc effectivement notre
culture qui m'a fait vraiment bastille
avec avec toute son influence le congrès
à lille où se situe une culture qu'il
m'a plu est différente d'une famille à
l'autre d'une personne à l'autre vous
dans votre famille qu'est ce que vous
mangez quand ce cycle urbain csu par
marquant pour vous comment il a essayé
de leurs produits avec mon enfant